congratulations you in 128 117 it's Le
go here I just want to ask you after
that one shot looked like something was
wrong with your shoulders is everything
okay yeah I'm all right I'm all right
I'm good you had you you had the wiggle
man how how was it feeling what was
getting into you there in the second
half it was hot it was hot that that
shoulder was a little hot I was trying
to cool it down um but yeah caught fire
and uh we we uh was able to finish this
one out uh sh here Kawai healthy you
playing well Russell deciding to come
off the bench James coming to his own
how far you think you guys can
go I think uh we we in the driver's seat
we control our destiny um we can go as
far as we want to go I think we
committed to to to one another which is
the most important uh thing for this
team PG 13 this is Candice playing
playing rated R tonight uh per usual but
how many open Catch and shoot threes are
you getting this year as opposed to
years's past being able to play with
guys like kawhai James Harden yourself
where you cannot be doubled because you
make the other team pay yeah I mean
those guys allow me to get in the Rhythm
and and honestly just line them up at
will um both of them require double
teams they they require so much
attention that uh a lot of times you
know it's I have the third best defender
on me um and and at that point you know
it's it's the team is at at our mercy so
playing off those guys definitely help
my game um and vice versa whenever I get
a chance to be aggressive to get them
open looks I try
to PG what's up it's Jamal Crawford uh
when you first said a while ago that you
know what Kawai is the number one I'm
the number two that was biger you I
think it helped set your team how do you
know on nights when it's time to be
number one like you were tonight and
just take over games and be who you are
cuz you're one of the best players in
the world still appreciate it I mean
it's it's honestly just reading the game
you know they they they going to double
team Kawai night in night out so to
alleviate that I got to get going I got
to be aggressive um to at least give him
opportunities to play one-on-one you
know every possession they're sending
two at him so the more I can be
aggressive the more I can try to take
control um it only opens up the game for
him and allows him to get comfortable so
you know that's just been my mindset you
know on on on you know any given night
and that mentality was just solely man I
just want to put everybody at ease I
know what I'm capable of I know what I
can do in this league one and two option
I know I'm going to get my fair share uh
honestly I'm just committed to to
winning and that's
it a season High 38 points for Paul
George and Paul listen to this man since
November 7th you guys are 23 and seven
best in the NBA keep staying hot brother
congrats yes sir appreciate you thank
you
guys